Peeing on the Moon... and 7 Other Awesome
Facts
1.
“Hack the System” blogger Maneesh Sethi
once hired a woman for $8 an hour to both
yell at him and slap him anytime she saw him
get off task from what he was supposed to
be doing while working.
He was having trouble staying focused as his
own boss, so thought this would be an easy
and cheap solution.
It turns out, it worked.
His procrastination time while working dropped
from 62% to 2% thanks to his slapping employee.
This man is a genius.
(QF 602)
2.
In 2005, a 22 year old man by the name of
Ronald MacDonald robbed a Wendy’s fast-food
restaurant (stealing the money in the store’s
safe) where he worked at the time.
(QF 591)
3.
From puberty to death, the average male will
produce enough sperm cells to theoretically
re-populate the entire planet Earth about
405 times at the present population level
of just over 7 billion people, producing about
1,500 sperm cells per second.
The average woman, on the other hand, will
only produce about 450 mature eggs suitable
for fertilization in her lifetime.
(QF 662)
4.
In 1670 in France, Louis XIV decreed that
if you committed suicide, your body would
be dragged through the streets face down and
then placed in a garbage heap.
Any property you may have owned, also would
be forfeit.
(QF 593)
5.
“Odd” and “Even” are popular names
for male children in Norway, but they have
nothing to do with mathematics.
The name “Odd”, in this instance, is after
the Old Norse word “Oddr”, a word for
the “sharp end” of some object or “edge
of a blade”.
“Even”, in this case, is from the Norse
“Eivindr”, which in turn comes from the
Old Norse “auja-“ and “-winduR”, meaning
“gift” or “winner”.
(QF 595)
6.
Buzz Aldrin was the first person to pee while
on the surface of the Moon.
Take THAT Neil Armstrong.
(QF 605)
7.
Hachikō was a dog who would greet his master
Hidesaburō Ueno at the Shibuya Station every
day for about a year when his master would
come home from work at the University of Tokyo.
Unfortunately, one day Ueno died while at
work and didn’t come home.
For the next nine years, until his own death,
the dog would show up when his master’s
train would arrive and wait for a time before
leaving when it was apparent his master wasn’t
coming home that day.
Hachikō finally died of cancer and was found
on the street on March 8, 1935.
Hachikō’s body was then stuffed and mounted
and can be seen at the National Science Museum
of Japan in Tokyo.
(QF 631)
8.
You should think twice before saying, “When
Hell freezes over.”
In fact, it freezes over quite frequent in
the small village of Hell, Norway where sub-zero
temperatures are not that uncommon in the
winter.
The name for the town derives from the Old
Norse “hellir,” which meant “cliff cave”
or “overhang”.
(QF 671)